>> Jon: WELCOME BACK!
SO RECENTLY WE SENT OUR INTREPID
REPORTER JASON JONES
OUT TO THE FIELD TO
EXPLORE THE PHENOMENON OF A
CERTAIN WASHINGTON D.C.'S
FOOTBALL TEAM'S CONTROVERSIAL
NAME. WE LEARNED
LATER THAT SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PIECE, THEY DIDN'T
ENJOY THE EXPERIENCE.
(LAUGHTER)
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS A
LOT LESS THAN YOU WOULD THINK.
BUT WE TAKE THE COMPLAINT
SERIOUSLY.
WE GENERALLY DON'T WANT PEOPLE
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE SHOW TO
HAVE A BAD EXPERIENCE.
WE WORK VERY HARD TO FIND REAL
PEOPLE WHO HAVE REAL BELIEFS AND
WANT TO EXPRESS THOSE BELIEFS ON
TELEVISION AND WE WORK HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE GIST OF THOSE
BELIEFS ARE RESPECTED
ACCURATELY -- ALBEIT SOMETIMES
COMEDICALLY ON OUR PROGRAM.
(LAUGHTER)
IF WE FIND OUT THAT SOMEONE IN A
PIECE WAS INTENTIONALLY MISLED
OR IF THEIR COMMENTS WERE
INTENTIONALLY MISREPRESENTED, WE
DO NOT AIR THAT PIECE.
WE WOULD NOT AIR THAT PIECE.
SO THAT BEING SAID, I HOPE YOU
ENJOY THE FOLLOWING PIECE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> FOOTBALL IS BACK, AND ONCE
AGAIN, THE WASHINGTON REDSKINS
ARE GETTING THEIR ASS KICKED.
BUT THIS TIME INSTEAD OF COWBOYS
AND PATRIOTS, IT'S BY LIBERAL
ACTIVISTS.
>> A MOVE IS UNDERWAY TO CHANGE
THE NAME.
CRITICS SAY IT'S OFFENSIVE TO
NATIVE AMERICANS.
>> BUT ACCORDING TO CHIEF DANIEL
SNYDER OF REDSKIN NATION, THE
ONLY CRIME HIS PEOPLE HAVE
COMMITTED
IS BEING MISUNDERSTOOD.
>> THE NAME OF OUR TEAM IS THE
NAME OF OUR TEAM AND IT
REPRESENTS HONOR, IT REPRESENTS
PRIDE, IT REPRESENTS RESPECT.
>> WELL, THAT DOESN'T SOUND THAT
BAD.
SO WHY WAS THIS GROUP OF NATIVE
AMERICAN ACTIVISTS SO UPSET?
>> IT'S A NAME THAT IMPAIRS,
DISABLES, DISENFRANCHISES OUR
POPULATION.
>> THE MOST POPULAR MASCOTS IN
THE COUNTRY ARE INDIANS AND
ANIMALS.
>> RIGHT.
BECAUSE WE ALL LOVE ANIMALS AND
WE ALL LOVE INDIANS.
>> WE'RE NOT MASCOTS.
>> THAT'S A DICTIONARY
DEFINED RACIAL SLUR.
>> YEAH BUT THAT'S ACCORDING TO
WHAT?
>> THE DICTIONARY.
>> OK BUT PLENTY OF WORDS IN THE
DICTIONARY HAVE MULTIPLE
MEANINGS. IT JUST TURNS OUT
THIS ONE DOESN'T.
HELP ME OUT, WHITE MAN.
>> TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT, YOU CAN
TAKE THINGS OUT OF CONTEXT ALL
OVER THE PLACE BUT IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE IT IS WHAT
IT IS, IT'S VERY OBVIOUS.
THAT THE NAME REALLY MEANS
HONOR.
>> HONORING WHAT?
>> YOUR STRONG, PROUD,
COURAGEOUS, BRAVE HERITAGE.
>> REDSKINS IS A BOUNTY.
>> IT MEANT PROOF OF INDIAN
KILL.
>> WELL WHEN YOU PUT IT LIKE
THAT, IT SOUNDS TERRIBLE.
PUT IT IN CONTEXT ON SUNDAYS --
>> AND SATURDAYS AND FRIDAY
NIGHTS.
>> AND MONDAYS.
>> AND LIVING IN D.C. EVERY DAY.
>> AND THURSDAY NIGHTS.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE A NATIVE IN THIS TOWN?
>> I DON'T. I DON'T. TERRIBLE.
>> TO WALK DOWN THE STREET EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND BE SURROUNDED BY
THAT IMAGERY AND BEING TOLD
TO GET OVER IT?
>> NO BECAUSE...
>> CAUSE, CAUSE, CAUSE...
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO, JUST
BECAUSE I'M UNCOMFORTABLE
DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE TO MAKE
FUN OF MY UNCOMFORTABLENESS.
YOU DON'T SEE ME DOING THAT TO
PEOPLE.
>> SURE THESE NATIVE AMERICAN
ACTIVISTS MAKE A COMPELLING
CASE. THAT IS UNTIL YOU
HEAR WHAT IS AT STAKE
FOR THE TRUE VICTIMS. THE FANS.
>> IF THE REDSKINS NAME IS
CHANGED AND I HAVE
CHILDREN ONE DAY, WHAT WOULD I
PASS ON TO THEM?
>> IT'D BE TOUGH. IT WOULD BE
LIKE LOSING A FAMILY MEMBER.
>> AND THEY'VE ALREADY LOST SO
MUCH, 58 STARTING
QUARTERBACKS, 28 HEAD COACHES,
12 UNIFORMS WITH TEN LOGOS,
PLAYING IN FIVE STADIUMS AND TWO
CITIES.
THEY EVEN CHANGED THEIR NAME
ONCE BEFORE SO FORGIVE THEM FOR
CLINGING TO WHAT FEW TRADITIONS
REMAIN.
(SINGING FIGHT SONG)
>> SING IT.
>>(SINGING) FIGHT FOR OLD D.C.
>> I HAVE AN OLDER COMPUTER. I
PULLED IT UP ON NETSCAPE.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE YOU DIDN'T SAY
THE WORD "SCALP 'EM."
>> IT ALSO SAYS WHOMP THEM, TOO.
>> OH, SO THE SONG CHANGED.
>> OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS
CHANGED FOR SENSITIVITY REASONS.
>> AND THE TEAM SENSITIVITY
HAS PAID OFF. I MEAN,
RIGHT HERE ON THE HOME PAGE OF
THE WEB SITE DANIEL SNYDER PAID
FOR, IT SAYS THAT, IN 2004, A
POLL FOUND THAT 90% OF NATIVE
AMERICANS DID NOT FIND THE NAME
OFFENSIVE.
>> THE ANNENBERG REPORT, THE
FUNNY THING ABOUT THE ANNENBERG
REPORT IS THAT IT WAS
CONDUCTED IN PENNSYLVANIA BY
SELF-IDENTIFYING INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE WHICH MEANS IT COULD HAVE
BEEN ANYBODY OFF THE STREET THAT
SAYS OH YEAH, MY GREAT GREAT
GREAT GRANDMOTHER WAS A CHEROKEE
PRINCESS.
>> COME ON. WHO WOULD DO THAT?
>> MY GREAT GREAT GREAT
GRANDFATHER WAS FULL BLOOD
CHEROKEE.
>> SHOW OF HANDS, WHO HAS
HAS CHEROKEE HERE? ANY NATIVE
AMERICAN.
BRIAN, WHAT DO YOU HAVE IN YOU?
>> CHEROKEE.
BUT I HAVE NO IDEA HOW MUCH OR
LITTLE.
>> RIGHT.
>> I'M ACTUALLY ONE-TWELFTH.
>> ONE-TWELFTH CHEROKEE.
>> AS ONE-TWELFTH CHEROKEE I AM
NOT OFFENDED.
>> WHICH MEANT THAT THERE
WAS ONLY ONE QUESTION FOR THE
OTHER 11/12. AREN'T YOU
BEING A LITTLE SENSITIVE?
>> AFTER EVERY SINGLE THING THAT
AMERICAN INDIAN PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN THROUGH, HOW CAN YOU
POSSIBLY SAY THAT WE ARE
THIN-SKINNED AND OVERSENSITIVE?
WE HAVE TO SAY THINGS LIKE,
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY BECAUSE AS
WE SAY RACISM OR RACIST --
>> NO ONE SAID RACIST.
>> THE WHOLE ARGUMENT SHUTS
DOWN.
>> EXACTLY. NO ONE SAID RACISM.
>> THE TERM IS RACIST.
>> OK, I'M SHUTTING THIS
CONVERSATION DOWN.
>> OK, SO REDSKI -- ALL RIGHT,
THE WASHINGTON TEAM NAME WAS
STARTING TO FEEL A LITTLE
INSENSITIVE. WHAT WAS I MISSING?
>> WHAT I WOULD SAY IS, COME TO
A FOOTBALL GAME, MEET SOME
FANS, COME SEE WHAT OUR
CONTEXT IS ABOUT AND I THINK,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S NO WAY YOU
WOULD LEAVE THAT OFFENDED.
>> SO I WENT TO A GAME. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT, IT WAS TRUE
I WAS IMMEDIATELY WELCOMED INTO
THIS RICH CULTURE,
AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT
WAS, BUT THE MORE TIME I SPENT
WITH THESE PEOPLE, THE MORE I
BEGAN TO FEEL WARM AND HAPPY AND
NUMB AND, THEY WERE RIGHT, THAT
LOGO IS COOL!
BUT THEN I MET WITH TRIBAL
ELDERS.
>> THIS IS OUR CULTURE.
THIS IS WHO WE ARE.
>> WOULD YOU CALL A NATIVE
AMERICAN A REDSKIN?
>> DO YOU KNOW ANY NATIVE
AMERICANS?
>> YEAH, ABOUT EIGHT OF THEM.
>> AM I NOT NATIVE AMERICAN?
WAS I NOT BORN IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> I DON'T WANT TO AUTHORIZE
THAT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS WAS A CULTURE SO PROUD THEY
DIDN'T EVEN WANT THEIR FACE ON
TV EVEN AFTER THEY HAD SIGNED
OUR RELEASE FORMS.
>> I WENT TO A GAME.
LET ME ASK YOU, IF YOU BROUGHT A
NATIVE AMERICAN,
WOULDN'T THEY BE A LITTLE UPSET?
>> I THINK THE CONVERSATION
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IS
THAT WE NEED TO BE SITTING DOWN,
TALKING TO THE PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY ARE OFFENDED.
>> A LITTLE LATER, WE DID JUST
THAT.
BUT IT TURNS OUT THESE FANS
WEREN'T COMFORTABLE HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION.
IN FACT, AFTERWARD, THEY RELAYED
TO "THE WASHINGTON POST" THAT
THEY FELT AMBUSHED, IN DANGER
AND DEFAMED AND, YES,
THE CONVERSATION WAS HEATED AT
TIMES BUT THERE WERE ALSO
HANDSHAKES AND EVEN THE
CEREMONIAL HANDKERCHIEF.
IN THE END, THEY SAID THEY STILL
WOULD HAVE GONE ON THE SHOW HAD
THEY KNOWN THERE WOULD BE
A DEBATE BUT AT LEAST ONE OF
THEM WOULDN'T HAVE WORN HIS RED
SKINS JACKET WHICH FORCES THE
QUESTION --
>> IF THEY CHANGE THE TEAM NAME,
WOULD YOU STILL ROOT FOR THEM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> UNEQUIVOCALLY.
>> I WOULDN'T HIDE MY REDSKINS
MEMORABILIA.
IT WOULD STILL BE ON THE WALLS,
THE BELT WOULD STILL BE ON THE
SHOULDER. THEY'LL ALWAYS
BE REDSKINS TO ME.
>> THERE WE GO. PROBLEM SOLVED.
HEY, HE WHO STANDS ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF HISTORY,
CHANGE THE (BLEEP) NAME.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: JASON JONES. WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK.